بين بريطانيا الملكيه وماركه جمهوريه محيط
واسع من التاريخ والجغرافيا والنظره
المختلفه الى مفهوم الحكم
الامريكيون جمهوريون في العمق وليسوا
مفتونين بالملكيه وفي هذه المساحه بالضبط
كان يفترض ان تتحول سلسله الامير هاري
وزوجته الامريكيه ناجن مركل الى نجاح ظهر
في الولايات المتحده لكن ذلك بكل بساطه لم
يحدث
الارقام مقلقه لزوجين ترك المملكه المتحده
وتوجهها للولايات المتحده
في بلد معجن لم يشاهد المسلسل الحدث سوا
مليون شخص من اصل
330,000,000 لم يتحول المسلسل الى الضربه
الشعبيه التي كانت متوقعه على عكس
بريطانيا
من الامير وزوجته ليس هناك بكل بساطه اي
قنبله فيما كشف عنه حتى الان على الاقل
[موسيقى]
دراسه صادمه اخرى تهز الزوجين الملكيين
المتمردين كيف زوجته ولي العهد وليام اي
شقيقه هاري باتت تتفوق على ميركل في
الشعبيه هنا في عقر دارها
ماكن المتمرده لا تبدو قادره على كسب
معركه الشارع مع الدقه الهادئه التي تسير
بحسب الاصول الملكيه
لا شك انها مفاجاه ولا شك انه تغيير
دراماتيكي في علاقه الاميركيين مع الملكيه
البريطانيه لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم
واشنطن